hagamos algunos cálculos usando la
ecuación de henderson hasselbeck
anteriormente vimos que la ecuación de
henderson hazel back es ph es igual a pk
a más el logaritmo de la concentración
de a menos entre la concentración de h
así que estamos hablando de un par
conjugado ácido base h
y menos ahora para nuestro problema el
ácido h sl nh4 más y la base a menos
sería nh3 el amoniaco entonces lo
primero que necesitamos para calcular el
ph de nuestra solución buffer también
conocida como solución amortiguador o
tampón es encontrar el pkk y nuestro
ácido es nh4 más y sabemos que el valor
de acá
para el nh 4 + es igual a 5.6 por 10 a
la menos 10 y para encontrar el pk
simplemente calculamos el menos
logaritmo de 5.6 por 10 a la menos 10
usemos la calculadora menos logaritmo de
5.6 por 10 a la menos 10 es igual a 9.25
el pk
es igual a 9.25 entonces vamos a
sustituirlo en la ecuación de henderson
hazel va el ph de la solución es igual a
9.25 más el logaritmo de la
concentración de a menos que ya dijimos
corresponde al amoniaco y miren su
concentración es 0.24 molar y entonces
0.24 entre la concentración del ácido
nh4 más y su concentración es 0.20 molar
entonces entre 0.20 molar usemos la
calculadora tenemos logaritmo de 0.24
0.20 esto es igual a 0.08 y 9.25 0.08 es
igual a 9.30 y 3 el ph es igual a 9.30 y
3 pero vamos a comparar este valor con
el ph de una solución buffer a la que le
agregaremos una base y otra a la que le
agregaremos un ácido primero veamos qué
pasa con el ph al agregar una base ahora
vamos a agregar 0.005 moles de una base
fuerte a la solución buffer y podemos
decir que el volumen total es de 0.50
litros entonces cuál es el ph resultante
bueno agregamos 0.005 moles de hidróxido
de sodio y el volumen total es 0.50
acuérdense si dividimos moles entre
litros obtenemos la concentración de
hidróxido de sodio
entonces 0.005 entre 0.50 es igual a
0.01 molar esta es la concentración del
hidróxido de sodio que es una base
fuerte y como es una base fuerte también
es la concentración de iones hidróxido
que hay en la solución entonces
agregamos una base y nuestra solución
buffer que contiene nh3 y nh 4 +
reacciona con el hidróxido la base
reacciona con el ácido reacciona con el
nh 4 más vamos a escribir la reacción
nh 4 más el ión amonio reacciona con el
hidróxido y es una reacción completa
entonces si el nh 4 + dona un protón al
h - el h - se transforma en h2o
obtenemos agua
y el nh 4 dona un protón nos queda nh 3
amoníaco ok ahora vamos a pensar en las
concentraciones ya calculamos que la
concentración de iones hidróxido es 0.01
molar y de iones amonio tenemos una
concentración igual a 0.20 molar 0.20
mientras que para el amoníaco era de
0.24 0.24 entonces como tenemos una
concentración 0.01 molar de iones
hidróxido todo eso va a reaccionar con
el amonio así que perdemos todo el
hidróxido y neutralizamos esa misma
cantidad pero de iones amonio con lo que
nos queda una concentración 0.19 molar
de amonio todo el hidróxido reaccionó y
como el amonio se transforma en amoniaco
todo lo que perdemos de amonio lo vamos
a ganar
amoniaco entonces ganamos 0.01 por lo
que la concentración final de amoniaco
es igual a 0.25 molar y ya podemos usar
nuestra ecuación de henderson hasselbeck
el ph es igual a pk
que ya sabemos es igual a 9.25 más el
logaritmo de la concentración de la base
que corresponde al nh3 y es igual a 0.25
entonces 0.25 entre la concentración del
ácido que corresponde al amonio y es
igual a 0.19 entonces entre 0.19 usemos
la calculadora tenemos logaritmo de 0.25
entre 0.19 esto es igual a 0.12 entonces
9.25 más
0.12 es igual a 9.37 el ph es igual a
9.37 comparemos este valor con el ph que
obtuvimos en el problema anterior
recuerden el ph de la solución buffer
era de 9.33 y al agregar una base el ph
aumentó pero miren muy poco esto nos
demuestra matemáticamente como una
solución buffer o amortiguador a resiste
los cambios bruscos de ph ahora veamos
qué pasa con el ph cuando agregamos un
ácido aún tenemos la misma solución
buffer inicial con amonio y amoniaco
pero esta vez en lugar de agregar una
base vamos a agregar un ácido tenemos
0.03 moles de hcl y supongamos que el
volumen total es de 0.50 litros entonces
nuestro objetivo es calcular el ph de la
solución final
calculemos la concentración de hcl
tenemos 0.03 moles entre el volumen
total que es 0.50 esto es igual a 0.06
molar esta es la concentración de hcl y
como hcl es un ácido fuerte sabemos que
se disocia en h + y cl - y como es una
solución acuosa h más y h2o forman h 3 o
más el johnny drone así que podemos
decir que 0.06 molar es la concentración
de iones y tronío presentes en la
solución ahora el ácido que agregamos va
a reaccionar con la base que está
presente en la solución buffet así que
esta vez reacción a la base es decir el
amoniaco vamos a escribir la reacción
entre el amoniaco nh3 y los iones hidro
no en la solución h 3
también es una reacción completa y si el
amoniaco toma un protón se transforma en
amonio nh4 más y si h3o más pierde un
protón nos queda h2o ok ahora la
concentración de iones sidronio es 0.06
molar 0.06 y la concentración inicial de
amoniaco es 0.24 molar entonces 0.24
mientras que de amonio es de 0.20 0.20
entonces como todos los iones hidro no
reaccionan perdemos todo y esa cantidad
que reacciona es la misma concentración
que perdemos de amoniaco perdemos una
concentración 0.06 molar al neutralizar
con h 3 o más entonces después de la
reacción nos queda una concentración
0.18 molar de amoniaco y recuerden lo
que perdemos de amoniaco lo ganamos de
amonio porque el amoniaco se transforma
en amonio así que ganamos 0.06 y nos
queda una concentración igual a 0.26 ya
estamos listos para usar la ecuación de
henderson hazel back el ph es igual a pk
que ya sabemos es igual a 9.25 más el
logaritmo de la concentración de la base
que es 0.18 0.18 entre la concentración
del ácido que corresponde al nh 4 más y
es igual a 0.26 entonces entre 0.26
usemos la calculadora tenemos logaritmo
de 0.18
y 0.26 esto es igual a menos 0.16 vamos
a escribirlo el ph es igual a 9.25 menos
0.16 y esto es igual a 9.09 así que el
ph es igual a 9.09 y recordemos que en
la solución buffer original
teníamos un phd 9.33 así que al agregar
un poco de ácido el ph bajó un poco pero
no extremadamente así que otra vez la
solución buffer o amortiguador puede
resistir los cambios drásticos de ph